[Music]
we just can't get enough at the Lyle
house so we took our obsession to the
next level and started reading loud
house fanfiction stay tuned to find out
about our favorite fanfic Stein the loud
family hey loud house fans if you want
more awesome videos like this one click
Subscribe now let's get to the 10 loud
house fan fics that are better than the
original I've literally been working for
three months to get as many likes on my
photos loud loud west we see a lot of
Laurie's boyfriend Bobby on the loud
house after all she is a 17 year old
girl it's normal to date at that age but
what about Lenny she's 16 and stylish
sure she isn't always the brightest
crayon in the box
but it's kind of weird that she never
dates right well if you've ever wondered
what type of guy Lenny would date look
no further than loud loud west on
fanfiction.net in this story the author
Vincent st. Germain has created an
awesome original character for Lenny's
boyfriend Oh Sees can be hit or miss in
fan fiction series but we are totally
loving this guy Kenny Dodgers has a
tough cowboy vibe going on but he's
actually a total sweetie just like Lenny
in the story Lenny brings her new
boyfriend and his parents over to meet
her giant family but Lauri is under the
impression that he is a huge bully she
has seen him act like a bully at school
and she goes into total overprotective
big sister mode she won't give him a
chance to explain the rest of the loud
siblings are totally impressed by how
awesome Kenny is but Lauri runs him off
it's got a happy ending though we love
seeing Lauri be all protective of Lenny
but we're glad she realizes her mistake
a special bond
speaking of Lauri we've got another
great pic featuring the eldest loud
sister sure Lauri can be really bossy
but you kind of have to be when you're
the oldest of eleven siblings but
overall she's a really great big sister
remember how upset all the loud kids
were when she tried to move into the
garage well one day Laura is going to
move off to college most likely in a
special bond on our
hive of our own writer Wyoming parmesan
takes a look at how the siblings will
react to Laurie leaving the author
focuses on how Lincoln will feel
especially be prepared to get all up in
your feelings with this story it's not
very long but it's super sweet Laurie is
loading all her stuff into the car to
take to college but then she realizes
Lincoln is nowhere to be found
she goes up to his room and she sees
that he is devastated about her leaving
she tries to reassure him and then she
tells him a story about when he was a
baby she reassures him that they have a
special bond it's an adorable story the
author is really talented which loud
sister do you think will have the
hardest time when Laurie goes off to
college
you guys better shake a leg there's a
ghost afoot the baby I learned to love
Wyoming parmesan on archive of our own
is really good at getting us in our
fields this author has also written
quite a few loud house fan fics
so they know the characters really well
imagine with the loud family what it
looks like when Lincoln was just a baby
there would have been five sisters and
Lynne would have been the youngest a lot
of times kids struggle when they are no
longer the baby of the family
and the baby I learned to love we find
out that Lynne wasn't always so keen on
being a big sister this story is written
in the first person from Lenz point of
view she talks about how much she loves
Lincoln he is pretty much her favorite
sibling but through a series of
flashbacks she reveals that that wasn't
always the case
he talks about her purse impression of
baby Lincoln and we can really see how
she grew to love him it's such a sweet
story the loud family may be crazy but
they all really love each other
this sort of feel-good story may not
make for great television since it isn't
just comedy but that's the great thing
about fan fiction we can see so much
more of the characters knick heroes
Halloween loud apparitions let's get out
of the lovey-dovey stories and talk
about a hilarious adventure one of the
best things about fan fiction is all of
the crossovers a lot of authors take
multiple fan
and mash them together for something
totally awesome and Knick heroes
Halloween loud apparitions does just
that
this is a loud house and Danny Phantom
across over Danny Phantom is another
Nickelodeon cartoon that was on the air
from 2004 to 2007 it was super popular
in the original show Danny Fenton was a
teenage boy who got ghost fighting
superpowers his superhero name was Danny
Phantom in this story by crapper geek on
fanfiction.net Lisa loud builds a ghost
portal to disprove Danny's dad's work on
ghosts she thinks there's a perfectly
scientific explanation for ghosts that
they are aliens with ghosts like DNA but
she accidentally lets an evil ghost
loose on the loud family the loud
siblings then have to go find Danny
Phantom and help him fight this evil
spirit and another old-school
Nickelodeon character makes an
appearance invader zim was a cartoon
that started in 2000 this is such a fun
story and it is really creative it's a
spooky story that is perfect for
Halloween an excellent night for an
exorcism
we found another great spooky fan
fiction story this time the star of the
thick is the luna la luna is such a
great character she's a total rocker and
she is overall one of the most fun loud
sisters Luna is also really important
because it is implied that she's
interested in both boys and girls there
aren't a lot of by cartoon characters so
this is a big deal and because of her
interest in Samantha sharp
there are a ton of Luna / Sam ships in
the fanfic world there is no right or
wrong way to write a fan fiction story
and an excellent night for an exorcism
really pushes those creative boundaries
mr. TyTy on archive of our own wrote
this story in the form of a poem or song
lyrics in the story Luna and Sam are
dating
they are also rocking out together but
somehow their rock music summons a demon
oh no Luna has to defeat the demon with
me
it's wild and fun and we love that the
whole story rhymes this one does have
some strong language though so make sure
your parents are okay with a few bad
words if they are you will love this
story mixed up Vincent st. Germain has
written quite a few loud house fan fics
on fanfiction.net he really knows the
characters and we love that he often
writes them just like a script he even
has Lincoln talking to the camera just
like in the real show one of the things
we love about his story mixed up is that
we get a heavy dose of Clyde Clyde is
such an awesome underrated character in
this Vic Lincoln finds out that Lynne
loud and Clyde are madly in love they
say opposites attract right well when
Lincoln finds out he is confused it's
not that he doesn't approve but he
doesn't know how to feel about it it's
pretty complicated to have your best
friend dating your sister after all when
Lola sticks her nose in the mess she
thinks Lincoln doesn't approve which
complicates things even worse Lola is
good at that isn't she mixed up isn't
the very long thick but it's a great
read we wonder if that will ever happen
on the TV show do you ship lead and
collide or are they too different to be
in love keep watching for another great
loud house ship from the fanfiction
world these are in charge Laurie is a
pretty busy girl she's on the goth team
and has a boyfriend so it's normal to
assume that she can't always be in
charge of her siblings when the parents
are out but who would she leave in
charge instead Linney is the next oldest
but she isn't all that smart what would
happen if Linney was left in charge of
all the younger loud siblings it can be
good Rick hammer still is an author on
archive of our own
he wrote the story in charge about
Lennie and in this hilarious Thicke
Lenny let's power get to her head Laurie
didn't want to leave Lennie in charge
but Lennie convinces her that she'll be
fine Lynne even takes extreme measures
to keep her siblings from acting up she
does things like gluing the
on Luna speakers and getting rid of
leashes chemicals
she keeps Lucy out of events by locking
them up she even takes away Lola's
makeup the siblings are not too happy
about this they go to Plan C to keep
Lenny from being in command but Lenny
really just wants to make Lauri proud
even though she kind of goes crazy with
a little power you still kind of feel
sorry for her we really love how Lenny
and Luna are portrayed in this story
it's a great read attack of the 50-foot
sister we loved that when one of Lisa
Lau's experiments backfires and that's
exactly what happens in attack of the
50-foot sister by s Thompson one you can
find this on fanfiction.net in this Vic
it's not exactly Lisa's fault though the
story opens with Lisa measuring all of
her siblings Flynn is really upset to
find out that Lincoln is taller than her
she's older so she feels like she should
be taller she is made fun of for this so
she decides to drink one of Lisa's
experiments to get taller but she ends
up too tall she grows to a gigantic 50
feet and destroys everything in her path
the siblings have to stop her from
destroying even more and figure out how
to shrink her back down the size at
first Lynne is pretty amused with her
new power one of the best things about
this story is that the author really
captured the humor and great one-liners
from the original show luan makes
terrible jokes as always Lucy calls her
sister an Empire State human the whole
story feels really authentic and true to
the characters if you like this writing
check out the author's longer fit called
Linkous loud house it's a gender Bend
where Lincoln is another girl in a
family full of sisters lefty loosie
loosie loud is one of the most
underrated loud siblings the goth girl
is kind of creepy and seriously dramatic
she spooks her siblings and is obsessed
with all things dark she's also a poet
we wanted to really get inside Lucy's
head and this [ __ ] is perfect for that
lefty-loosey was written by we villain
on archive of our own in this story Lucy
has broken her arm she can ride for two
whole months she takes it really hard
bored and miserable and is so dark and
dramatic about the whole thing
she sighs a lot and she compares her
broken arm to things like being buried
alive or being a zombie her flair for
the dramatic is so funny
that's just so Lucy her younger sister
Lana blames herself for Lucy's accidents
but Lucy doesn't we get to see Lucy be a
good big sister and reassure Lana it's
decided Lucy we don't really get to see
in the TV show Lucy and Lana bond in a
sweet but hilarious way it's a really
creative story and we just love seeing
more of Lucy and Lana
we can't recommend this Vic enough yeah
killing me and I think I've got a fever
Veronica the later years all you Ronnie
and Lincoln shippers out there rejoice
we have not just one fanfic for you but
a whole series Ronnie Anne is Lincoln's
crush in the loud house she's the
toughest girl in school on archive of
our own author Wyoming Parmesan has
written a series of fix about Ronnie man
and Lincoln as adults who are dating and
later married the first Vic the advice
of a sister is about the trouble they
have when they first move in together
my girl is the quick romantic read about
a date night does he care too much is
all about what it's like to be married
to Lincoln Ronnie Ann is pregnant in
this story and finally new baby blues is
all about their first child whose name
starts with an L of course it's a
totally awesome series Ronnie Ann and
Lincoln are a great couple
we love to imagine that they grow up and
get married they totally bond over
having a large family each of the
stories is a quick read but they are
totally well written and the author just
updated on September 30th 2018 you can
subscribe to the whole series in case
they post more who is your loud house
OTP is it Ronnie Caen let us know in the
comments those are 10 amazing loud house
fan fiction stories and might be even
better than the original show if you
want more awesome videos check out our
community page and don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]